it is great to be joined today by
Jonathan Hite who is a social
psychologist and professor at New York
University's Stern School of Business
he's the author of two New York Times
bestsellers including the righteous mind
the new book co-authored with Greg
lukianov
is the coddling of the American mind
Jonathan so great to talk to you I
really appreciate you joining me my
pleasure David there's so much to talk
about and so much in your book that's
relevant to what's going on in the sort
of American state of politics right now
and I was sort of struggling with how to
maybe enter the conversation and maybe
one way would be if we want to think now
about the ways in which the American
electorate sort of exists in its
polarized State there are lots of
hypotheses about the spectrum we should
be looking at there is religion there's
race
there's simply left-right political
ideology there is Authority Rhian versus
libertarian all of these different ways
if I were to just open it up to you and
say what is the most relevant lens in
your mind through which we can
understand American political
polarization now what would it be so I
would say that we are we are we've gone
through a long transition in which long
ago material interests and then race and
other identity factors were the primary
the primary determinants of political
coalition's but as societies get
wealthier and more educated morals polit
morals and personality actually end up
becoming more and more important so it's
crucial to understand why we're in such
a mess now you have to understand that
the late 20th century was a real anomaly
throughout the mid 20th century we
actually had and into the late century
we had conservative Democrats in the
south we had liberal Republicans in the
Northeast in the west coast so things
weren't our parties were not perfect
personality sorts and now they are if
you give someone a personality test you
can now guess which side they're on
there's a wonderful report out from a
group in Britain called more in common
they put out this hidden tribes report
and they've
found that when you when you give
Americans a whole bunch of attitude
questions that are not even about
politics just about morals and values
that does a better job sorting people
then if you know everything that their
race and religion and other things is
there or let's see how I can couch this
is there something about the political
systems set up that is fomenting the
polarization that we're seeing in the
sense that from from an electoral
perspective there's not that much
incentive to sort of find common ground
and get along for both reasons of how
politics is financed and for other
reasons so I guess the question is does
the political system foment disagreement
and polarization yes in a lot of ways so
let's start with this the worst number
of political parties to have in a
country is one okay that's really bad
but the second worst number is probably
two there's even research showing that
if you have two contestants they you get
you know all the the normal stuff of us
versus them if you simply add another
one somewhere even if it's not that
important the the hatred here becomes
less there's something about us versus
them that really activates our ancient
tribal circuits so having a two-party
system as we do in America it was not
the founders intent but it that it
became the reality even as they were
debating the Constitution whereas in
Europe they have parliamentary systems
those are a little more resistant to
this kind of nasty polarization that's
one then there's also the fact that our
electoral system most of our states have
closed party primaries and so since very
few people turn out to vote in the
primaries it's mostly the the passionate
extremists so our primary system tends
to choose people who are who are more
expressive shall we say then there's
change in the media environment and so
now here there's some asymmetry but
people who have more extreme views can
have a pretty good career especially in
the right-wing media space obviously the
the left does tend to dominate the
mainstream media so I'm not I'm not
trying to take sides here but I think
the facts are the mainstream media does
lean left the right leaning media is
more of a sort of commercial outrage
industry there's a book called the
outrage industry that I think
a really good job of that so for a whole
bunch of reasons the mid to late 20th
century was unusual in you might say
having a lot of centripetal forces
pulling us together and the overlap of
the parties the liberal concern Liberal
Democrats ed without that issue and then
the fact that we had three television
networks for the much of the century
that we're fairly centralizing for a lot
in a lot of ways those centripetal
forces that were very strong mid
twentieth century including having
common enemies from Hitler through
through the Soviets those fell away in
the late 20th century an especially the
early 2000s and now the centrifugal
force is blowing us apart are much
stronger than they've been in a long
time I think can we go back a little bit
to I want to see what your thoughts are
on this idea that the mainstream media
other than the right-wing outrage
industry is is predominantly left
because when I look at analyses that
look at sort of people's beliefs based
on the media that they consume I'm not
really seeing that leftward lean I'm
seeing a very sort of pro-corporate lean
when it comes to as I call it the
corporate media rather than mainstream
media but on what sort of empirical
basis can we say most mainstream or
corporate media leans left so if you
look at the like the Big Five
personality truth there's a lot of
research on personality and occupation
and so people who score high on openness
to experience tend to gravitate to the
arts and media and the Academy so that
my my part of the world the Academy
leans left and most of that is just
natural selection just like look if you
serve a police departments and military
and you know large parts of the
corporate world they tend to lean right
in a free society people gonna choose
jobs that they like and so people who
choose to be reporters who choose to
live a life of uncovering the truth
uncovering scandal questioning power the
media always attracts more many more
people on the left and the right so even
at The Wall Street Journal as far as I
know most of the actual reporters forget
the editorial page that's a whole
separate kettle of fish but the
reporters tend to be Democrats
even when I've spoken at military
academies you know you think the Academy
leans left but you'd think like at West
Point or in the Military Academy you
think they'd be conservatives and no
even there they tend to lean left
they're just not nearly as far left so a
lot of this is just very natural part of
a free society reporters tend to lean
left and so when you look at when you
look at the way news is covered we look
at the subtle choices made again this is
not a conspiracy theory I mean I think
that there are our best journal you know
the New York Times the I think the
Atlantic is a wonderful publication they
have very high journalistic standards
I'm not saying all the mainstream media
I'm just saying just as a fact about
who's in the industries it tends to be
people who are voting for the Democrats
and that has a subtle influence where as
demonstrate that I mean in other words
so I'm completely I'm in agreement with
you that it that there's no question
that it seems as though the majority of
reporters are sort of self-identified on
the left but if we want to make an
analysis about the impact of that on
polarization we may want to demonstrate
that that's coming through in a way that
is biasing the audience and I guess
that's what I've not seen oh so there's
a huge amount of research literature on
whether it matters I don't know that
literature so I can't comment on it okay
but I think what you know the most
reasonable the most reasonable way to
approach this I think is to say that
there's not a symmetry that is you know
there are issues with their issues with
the mainstream media that I again I
think it's generally and now I think
we're really coming to appreciate the
value of having professionals handling
the news rather than you know any any
person with a with a website and a
following whereas the the right-wing
media has evolved especially in the
shadow of original cable TV which
allowed narrow casting so again the book
here is called the outrage industry by I
forget the first author but the second
author is Sarah so barrage that's a
wonderful book if you want to understand
more about how this all works let's talk
about this ace from asymmetrical
circumstance that we sort of find
ourselves in one element that I've sort
of been following is that there seems to
be a sort of asymmetrical polarization
or radicalization that has taken place
I'm curious whether you agree
one such example would be that if we
look at the abortion debate just to pick
one I mean we could pick any issue that
we have seen what I've identified as
more and more radical positions on the
right whereas the position on the left
does not seem to have have gone further
to the left it's not abortions all the
time up until a child is ten years old
right there has not been a sort of
symmetrical it's a sort of a natural
stopping point there's a natural
stopping point that we've seen that's
one example and there could be others do
you agree that there's been an
asymmetrical radicalization that has
shifted the Overton Window to the right
or am i biased in perceiving that kind
of both so let's let's take it one step
at a time there's a wonderful book
called it's even worse than it looks by
Norm Ornstein and Thomas Mann who are
who are really experts on Congress now
norm Ornstein is at AEI a conservative
think-tank but he personally is more of
a progressive I think but I think
they're both I like them both a lot I
think they're very wise yeah and when
their book came out in 2012 they had
some great phrase that got repeated all
around it was like that it was about
asymmetric polarization was about the
Republican Party has become what do they
call it a an insurgent outlier like
basically the Republican Party by 2010
and so it began with with Newt Gingrich
had evolved had moved further to the
right was doing more and more things
that very least you could they challenge
or subvert of the norms of Congress so I
do agree that the the right changed more
the right moved more now there are some
political scientists and some
conservatives who who dispute this this
is the difficulty of social science you
make an argument with one data set
somebody else as well but you look at
something else but I think it is fair to
say that the Republicans got more
radical more angry and were more likely
to act in ways that were out of
character out of the the character of
Congress in previous decades with that
said though I think we do have to point
out that we since since especially 2000
since the George W Bush administration
and maybe it goes back to the late
Clinton administration there's been an
incredible rage visible in whichever
party doesn't control the White House so
so you know under Clinton there were all
kinds of conspiracy theories and a lot
of people who hated him but under under
george w bush people talked about bush
derangement syndrome there were some
people on the Left who couldn't think
clearly because they hated bush so much
and then Obama comes in and suddenly
those people become sane again but now
there's an even more radical insane
far-right with all their conspiracy
theories and some people who proposed
that Trump wasn't I think that that
Obama was born in America and now of
course with Trump in the White House
many people on the left or even more
crazy now I don't want to say that Trump
is similar to Obama and it's just going
back and forth Trump is not I mean Trump
is beyond anything we've ever had in the
White House I think he's I can't speak
as a psychologist I'm not a clinical
psychologist but his personal behavior
and and the way that he thinks is not
how to put it he is seems to be playing
a game where everything is mostly about
him rather than necessarily about policy
that's the most polite way to put it I
suppose but III think that we cannot see
what's going on unless we at least hear
from the other side so every time I've
tried to say look at look at all the
innovations the Republicans did that are
subverting democracy my conservative
friends will point out something that
the Democrats did too so I'm just saying
it's hard to know the truth until you
listen to all the sides is there I've
interviewed David Dunning of the
dunning-kruger effect and we've talked
about sort of the limits that sometimes
people have to identify flaws in their
own thinking or to understand why they
may not fully understand something is
that lack of metacognition something
that plays a particular role in politics
or is it just metacognition as a
phenomenon that exists for Homo sapiens
broadly but it's not particularly
pernicious in politics yeah oh my
goodness well you know my last book the
righteous mind it was all about how we
evolved to play certain games in
small-scale societies of 5,250 people we
are much more concerned about a
reputation than we are about just about
anything else with the possible
exception of our children and so I I
side with the various cognitive
psychologists who have argued that that
language and reasoning evolved not
help us find the truth but to help us
manipulate others and play the social
game of reputation management so that's
part of social life and in politics it
just ramps it up so it's very eat you
know I read a lot about post hoc
reasoning and motivated reasoning and
it's easy to see that in other people
and you know it's really hard to see it
in yourself and when you could then go
to politics it's even easier to see it
in the other people and often harder to
see it in yourself
what I would add here is that this isn't
just about individuals and their flaws
this is about group versus group
fighting for the future of the country
people feel as though it's an
existential battle and it is it's much
more so now than than it wasn't in many
previous decades
so it's group versus group and so
anybody who tries to see new on it's
like you know if you're on the Left how
many people have you heard on the Left
say I disagree with Trump on almost
everything but you know I think he was
right on 0.3 it's very hard to say that
because if you if you suggest that maybe
there's some nuance here you could
suffer some real social blowback and
again this is nothing particularly about
the left obviously the right is quite
savage about its Mavericks you know we
in general we like Mavericks when
they're from the other party but a
maverick in our own party is a traitor
and we generally hate them yeah I
actually identified three points that I
don't totally disagree with Trump on two
of them I forgot just while we've been
paddler but I'm gonna try motivating
that that's a good because good place to
pause we're speaking with Jonathan Hite
the most recent book co-authored with
Greg lukianov is the coddling of the
American mind we will take a break and
pick up our conversation with him
tomorrow we're continuing our
conversation today with Jonathan Hite
who is a social psychologist professor
at NYU Stern School of Business we are
speaking about a lot of things but
partially at least about his new book
co-authored with Greg lukianov
the coddling of the American mind let's
maybe pick up our conversation on the
topic of values I've recently
interviewed a lot of interesting and
different people including Nathan J
Robinson and many others and there seems
to be somewhat of a split about whether
one side in order to convince the other
side
to use sort of simple terms when it
comes to politics whether it's useful to
make arguments that appeal to what we
perceive the others values to be in
other words if you are on the left and
you are for a woman's right to choose
and for you the values of the right on
abortion aren't really the important
ones is it effective to use values that
sound like they are the ones of your
opponents in order to get people to
re-examine their beliefs do you think
that that's a useful tactic or not a
particularly useful oh yes I mean so
first of all it's straight out of Dale
Carnegie how to win friends and
influence people is you talk to people
about their interests not about yours
second there is direct research on this
let me see if I can find the references
Feinberg and Willer there's a team of
social psychologists who let me see if I
can find a research summarizing their
point but they basically instructed
people like Feinberg has a TED talk on
this where they instructed people to
make arguments about something people on
the left or people on the right make
arguments the other side and people will
spontaneously make the argument in terms
of their own side's moral values they
used the moral foundations theory a
theory that I and some other social
psychologists created where we basically
find that people on the Left tend to
base their appeals on issues of care and
fairness where fairness is often about
equality and whereas conservatives have
that but conservatives also value a lot
group loyalty respect for authority in a
sense of sanctity or purity so at least
there are these there are some
differences of value between the left
and the right and people will
spontaneously catch an argument in their
own sides values and it's not very
effective at persuading others but if
you tell them why don't you redo this
but now put it in terms of the other
side's values they can do it and it
actually is more persuasive so I think
we know the answer now obviously if you
if you do it badly if you if you do it
clumsily and and you you know you
alienate the person it's gonna backfire
but if you can do it skillfully yes
that's that's like the secret of
political persuasion what do you make of
the way in which values have been
sort of a battleground within this
context of what is sometimes called the
social justice warrior phenomenon or the
virtue signal signaling social media
phenomenon it and I guess what I mean by
that is the use of values to signal
others in a way that maybe is not the
most productive when it comes to the
actual arguments and problems we're
trying to figure out I guess question
one is how big of a problem do you think
it is because I've as someone on the
Left been critical of that where I see
it existing I just don't think it's
nearly as big a problem if some have
made it out to be yeah I think it's a
much bigger problem and some have made
it out to be
really this yeah and this is the reason
so if you and I are talking in private I
might actually be trying to persuade you
yeah but if we're talking in front of a
thousand people I don't actually care
about you I'm totally focused on looking
good in front of the in front of my
people and so if I'm gonna if I'm gonna
say think I'm gonna get credit if I'm
gonna manage my reputation the stronger
the harder I hit the more uncompromising
I am the more I show that I'm on the
right side to my people the better that
is to me I don't care about the whole
world I care about the people that are
in my group or that are gonna judge me
and so social media unfortunately puts
us puts us all in this situation where
we're whatever we say we will be judged
and so we're signaling where we've
always been incentivized to signal but
here's what I think has happened
especially to young people social media
has put them into what you might call an
economy of prestige where the way you
get credit is by showing either that
you've been victimized or by standing up
for someone else who has been victimized
and so this is what leads to a call out
culture if somebody says something
perfectly innocent but you find a way
that you can say well that's racist or
sexist like you know a teenager wears a
dress with a Chinese Chinese theme to it
and you find a way you can call her out
for that for insensitivity you might get
points in your team but the rest of the
world you look ridiculous you look
incredibly intolerant small-minded um so
that incident I forget the young woman's
name
or this Chinese dress to her prom yeah
the fact that people tried to shame her
that looks really really bad for the
left and when you have a succession of
these things it's pretty much every day
you've got a story like that so many
people and remember America I mean
there's a there's 8% on the left that
are the progressive activist tribe
that's what this this hidden tribes
report says there's 6% on the far right
that are the committee conservatives
that those are the real authoritarians
and a lot of them are really racist you
got those two extreme groups but most
Americans are somewhere in the middle
they're still pretty open-minded they're
willing to compromise if the left loses
them if the left turns off a lot of
people who otherwise lean left that's a
big problem and I think that could be a
big problem for the Democrats going into
2020 depending on which way they go here
yeah I guess I'm just not sure so I
completely agree with your analysis I
just am not seeing that it's a
predominant narrative on the left in
other words I everyday you know whenever
I take phone calls from the left it's
wide open phones people can call in and
ask about anything they want we get
emails we get facebook comments you know
I'm paying attention to what's going on
in prominent Twitter left-wing influence
circles I just don't see that much of it
the majority of the discussion I'm
seeing is about how can we get health
care to everybody even if they can't
afford it how can we reduce income
inequality why aren't we dealing with
the climate and so I guess how can we
empirically identify that this is really
a major problem yeah so if you're within
a discourse community most people are
pretty reasonable even if you're just
within the discourse community of
activists on the Left mm-hmm most people
are well-intentioned mentally stable you
know interested in policy and so let's
suppose a thousand things are said in
your community and five of that thousand
are kind of like crazy you know
you know intolerant yeah what's called
the intolerant lab well in your
community you say look we're pretty
reasonable but it's those five comments
that are going to be retweeted and shown
on right-wing media now it turns out the
Russians we're doing a lot of this I
mean you know we're all pretty good at
being Russian BOTS ourselves that was
the finding of a big study at MIT that
you don't need Russian BOTS to get
polarization but it turns out we just
learned you know this week
the Russians were doing even more than
we thought to cause racial conflict
left-right conflict so within your
community most people are reasonable but
it generates enough stuff that there's a
daily diet every single day people on
the left and the right send me things
with basically the messages can you
believe those people they're completely
sick and it's from both sides because
there are 350 million of us in this
country and every day between ten and a
hundred on each side do horrible things
and we should mostly just ignore them I
mean we used to ignore them because we
didn't know about them but social media
means that we know about all the worst
things from the other side every day and
that makes it very hard to keep our
minds we're all losing our minds because
we are stuffed every day without Rage
stories and the other side is stuffed
with outrage stories - so I'm very
pessimistic about the future of our
country and actually the future of
Western democracies I don't know you
know I imagine someday we'll find a way
to adapt to it but the way that social
media is now it just sort of taps in or
Jack's in - are so many circuits in our
minds that I think it is driving us
crazy and it's gonna make it very
difficult for us to coexist with people
on the other side some people refuse
even to work with someone who voted for
the other candidate yeah it seems I mean
when I hear you talking about that it
seems to suggest that in some way the
problem is that of how others react to
these enclaves that exist we've been
talking about this one on the left as
you said it exists on the right because
even if we're talking about a small
percentage of people the destructive
impact of it is what to me seems like
it's a disabling a serve self-inflicted
error that the left makes when it
focuses it focuses on these issues
because it sort of prevents reasonable
debate from even taking place that's
right
plus here's another thing that I think
people on the left it would really help
to understand so I'm in a world in which
everybody's on the Left I mean there's
like five people I could name that are
conservatives in the Academy and now are
you saying you're at NYU or what do you
mean five like no like okay I'm
exaggerating there's more than five
conservative academics okay in terms of
like no but if you ask professors like
named a conservative academic I mean
they're like four or five that we can
all name and beyond that we kind of run
out
so it's a very lab I mean every it's not
that everybody's on left per se there
are actually turns out there there are a
fair number of moderates but there's
hardly anybody right a center my point
is just that
more and more every year every month I
find more and more people who are on the
left and they said some innocent thing
and they were crucified for it
they were shamed they were called racist
sexist homophobic we know but you
misunderstood it doesn't matter and when
that happens these people get very
bitter I mean when you're falsely
accused and especially if you're
publicly shamed you get very bitter and
so there's a wonderful line from I think
it's performed the Bell Tolls which
every Hemingway novel is in Italy and
World War one and at some point if I
remember correctly at some point decide
he was fighting for they know they end
up shooting at him and he gets totally
disillusioned like and he says and
suddenly the whole war mattered to me
about as much as somebody else's college
football game and I think this happens
to a lot of people when you get because
they they always come back sit but wait
I'm very progressive wait I you know I
did this and I did this I didn't you
know I really good progressive
credentials but that that defense
doesn't help you you were still publicly
shamed and when this happens to people
it really
you're losing allies you're alienating
people and if it's people who aren't
attached to the left but we're in the
center you're pushing them to Trump and
a lot of people voted for Trump because
they're just sick and tired of being
ashamed for what they said what they
think are not not offensive statements
so yeah you generally don't win people
over to your side by attacking them and
so the more the more people of a sliver
of the left the more they accuse people
in their in their schools and their
companies wherever they are the more
accusations they make the more support
the left loses to sort of start winding
down our conversation to take that and
look at another election that you've
commented on you've argued that
Democrats in 2000 and 2004 lost
partially if I understand your position
correctly because they couldn't discuss
morality in a way that was effective for
them to garner votes what do you mean by
that
so the so a bunch of us were writing
about this at the time you can find a
similar argument in George Lake off
moral politics and in drew Weston's
book the I think was called the the
political brain we were all noticing
that from Ronald Reagan through George W
Bush Ronald Reagan was quite eloquent he
could do this on his own
george w bush was not eloquent but he
had good speech writers the republicans
would talk about politics and this is
only true about national politics local
politics is dirty business local
politics is not like religion national
politics in the united states is like
religion and the president puts himself
forth with a candidate puts himself
forth as the high priest of the american
Civic religion and you have to talk
about how Great America is and the flag
and the founding documents and the
founding fathers American values the
American dream so the Republicans have
always been good at this and the
Democrats many of them have not now
Clinton was great Clinton could do it
and it's important that he's from the
south but but especially when I was
growing up in Michael Dukakis and then
of course Al Gore and John Kerry their
approach to winning the presidency was
we have a policy and our policy gives
you more than the other guys policy and
so you know we care about you because
we're gonna give you a better better
program and that doesn't it doesn't stir
the heart so I think the Democrats
tended to misunderstand they tended to
think that the way to persuade someone
is to appeal to their interests now
Obama was much better Obama is very
eloquent and Obama I my wife and I fell
in love with Obama when we listened to
Dreams from My Father
we listened to that book on tape and or
CD and and he reads it and he does all
the voices and like he you know he
unjustly he understands black people
white people Indonesians America like he
really understands people and he could
speak to their values especially as a
candidate not not quite as good once in
office but he was I think of wonderful
candidate at doing that so so yeah
that's that's what I meant you have to
understand the religious nature of all
social life well of especially of
politics and sports and other other
group ish activities and the Democrats
were slow to figure that out
we've been speaking with Jonathan Hite
the most recent book co-authored with
Greg lukianov is the coddling of the
America
in mind Jonathan thank you so much for
speaking with me I appreciate it
my pleasure Dave